bien des montréalais n'ont pas oublié le
lien de kamala harris avec la métropole
de plus pour tous les montréalais ça
vaut la peine de décès du quai de
poursuivre tous les rêves sont possibles
même en tant que femme son courage tout
le monde je suis sûr à 12 ans la
vice-présidente américaine est venue
s'installer à montréal avec sa famille
elle a complété ses études secondaires
ici à l'école ouest mènera en 1981
presque quarante ans plus tard la
direction de l'école et les élèves ont
souligné la journée d'investiture en
classe je pense qu elle est pratiquement
un symbole de tout ce que les états unis
doit être une de celles qui ont été très
proches de kamala harris lors de ses
années au secondaire conserve un
souvenir unique de son ami de l'époque
actuelle vice-présidente pourrait bien
un jour revenir à montréal
la direction de la commission scolaire
english 28 ans combien lui lancé
l'invitation prochainement
nous avons exprimé une intention de
d'éviter comme pour venir
on espère et quel plus le visiter chacun
ici mélissa françois radio canada
montréal